Joe Giudice is ready for battle as the
Real Housewives of New Jersey star waits
to learn his fate after his latest
deportation appeal in Italy he's staying
busy by kicking some serious butt
literally Joe and Teresa's oldest
daughter gia shared a few clips of her
dad on Instagram yep that's the reality
star working hard to maintain his
dramatic weight loss with some seriously
impressive martial arts moves okay Joe
the 18 year old captioned the video
quote we come back stronger than before
the fights just starting gia also shared
this clip of Joe running through drills
with his brother Pete who is staying
with him in Italy so gia made sure to
give her uncle a a big shoutout to
writing zio Pete you're a great coach
we saw rumors that Joe wants to become
an MMA fighter if when he finally gets
out is that true a source recently told
et that Teresa is so proud of Joe for
his physical transformation quote Joe
worked out twice a day every day to lose
the weight and in the end he lost more
than 50 pounds then there was this yeah
if you're a fan of the Bravo reality
show you know Joe is a man who can slay
the splits
ouch gia shared the video on her instace
story and get this guy's after showing
off his um flexibility Joe speaks out
for the first time since his released
from an ice facility last Friday
Joe was released from prison in March
after serving three years behind bars
after pleading guilty to multiple
charges of fraud in 2014 before his
release a judge ordered Joe who's an
Italian citizen to be deported but he
appealed that decision after his release
he was transferred to ice custody and
last month a judge denied Joe's bond
when he asked to leave the ice facility
and go home to his family while a
decision in his deportation appeal was
being made a judge later agreed to let
Joe returned to Italy where he was born
while it's being decided whether he'll
be able to return to the US he's gonna
get shipped out of the damn country I
don't know if I'm ready to let him go
our family ET recently caught up with
Teresa who told us how her family is
doing during this trying time my
daughters are doing well so hanging in
there
they're doing good thank God they're
pretty amazing they're strong you know
strong young women
I guess they get it from their mommy now
in a new trailer for the Real Housewives
of New Jersey the reality star questions
where the marriage stands amid his
deportation case if Joe is deported and
goes to Italy will you go there with him
no I probably wouldn't you feel like
you're still in love with him
I don't know I haven't been happy in so
long I just want to be happy again in
another scene Teresa shows her co-stars
a pic of a shirtless man that isn't Joe
were you guys messing around he might
have kissed I don't know about you guys
but I cannot wait to watch all this
drama unfold when the season 10
premieres on November 6th something
tells me it's going to be a wild ride
of course et will be here to keep you in
the know on all things Real Housewives
so make sure to keep it locked right
here until next time I'm Hallie Stevens
bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]